hello the nation of the reject love
I'm Greg Alba and I am John Humphrey
yeah we're going to watch the trailer
today for a little show called the
gifted this is coming out on Fox it is
connected to the x-men Cinematic
Universe it's the other x-men show yeah
but it's more it's more addicted it's
sort of like it's not it's doing its own
thing I hear but it's not yeah it's a
trip like now
yeah like legions more like is this
connected it sounds like where is this
you're going to like you know but it's
not going to go out of its way to try to
really make it like time to the movies
and Bryan Singer director the pilot so
as far as I know about it including its
miniature synopsis let's do it
[Music]
is employer
[Music]
even if he shows gets rated fun we're
very troubled young woman Oh turn
believe it or not I'm here to help you
you know when you put your hand under
the window of the living car you can
feel the air and guide it
I can push the air together one or two
other steps got your dastan you let me
teach you that that's what I would use
my pencils I understand you have some
concerns about yourself Andy and I have
always been very close but we believe
he's being bullied it accrues here so
it's very disguised my stupid earth
crazy
maybe hear about Andrew and Lauren aware
that there was a bit of an incident at
school this evening oh man I need you to
go game for me they're not going
anywhere
we have to secure the safety Harry
no fear about the weakness those are my
kids you have to help them didn't use
powered dad put people like in jail my
experience exchange missing kid there's
nothing more important to me and my
family the excellent before the real
know they exist in you know I think
doesn't think about what's best for your
friends
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
this is a person chest
[Music]
there's some powerful gift Wow young
about mourning the information I have is
yours no makes my family
I am movie the thing is all I can think
of this whole trailer opal oh the chills
are bound to follow you think it was the
winter by how chilly those minutes for
were you thinking oh this is just the
one thing I kept getting distracted by
in this trailer with your family guy
when like the Harrison Ford airplane
movie comes up and one of the bits they
do and the gag is just they cut away
it's giving back my family that's all I
just think about every time they showed
Stephen Moyer because like it's the only
thing he says this Holt right now
everything with him as someone going
your family I'm sure a lot of it adjust
from the season not from just a pilot
episode I like I like that unless it's
just a very long pilot with a lot of
thing to it had a moocher link but yeah
I like it I do I think it's really cool
I know I really enjoy most of the x-men
films a hell of a lot and this looks
like the more I don't know work for him
the more human versions of like an x-men
type of story because you know they
clearly said like we don't even know if
the x-men exist right now so not sure
specifically what point in time and it's
and in the world are at in terms of
where the x-men exists and what they
know of the Brotherhood of them however
with that being said I like this story
of a feat of a family on the run with
the parents being humans and theirs and
their children being me as because every
time you're seeing the x-men movies I
can't recall I might be wrong because
it's a lot of excellent movies to think
about here where I'm saying this but I
think of like how the parents who are
humans always rejected their mutant
child there's that famous line that is
that was a famous line was it one of my
lines I really remember from x2i smash
parent say have you ever tried not being
a mutant in here these parents or humans
but it'll do anything for their family
I like I like since I forget strong
human care like the human characters
look just as a dream to me as a beauty
characters actually I think parts this
looks like a family drama to me like one
of those at serious issue kind of based
shows because I mean it's it's cool that
they're using the platform for like with
my favorite thing on the x-men movies is
like they've lend themselves to being
allegories and so this kind of story is
a decent one to tell right now you know
they're taking advantage of it beyond
just having a cool superhero show yeah
and that stuff they look like they were
pouring just as much effort into as the
cool way we're messing up the gym it
seems like you can really deal with the
human drama having a you know having
this these children is as mutants make
an excellent movie not gonna have time
for that [ __ ] yeah exactly yeah
two hours ago you got thrown a few big
action scenes you got to do a lot you
can't hit a car cause it had the same
timeline it just doesn't work there's a
good timing after Logan I think we get
Logan was the most human portrayal of
any of these x-men movies ever well
again this is this is where superhero it
is intriguing mean again yeah
intriguing me more because I got imagine
this as in response to Marvel has their
shows on ABC and on Netflix and then
they have the DC shows on the CW and now
Fox is jumping in with their x-men
universe and those have Gotham there
yeah on Fox yeah okay so yeah focus to
[ __ ] what Gotham and now this like I
think it's cool that this in Legion or
coming out around the same time because
this is their life hard-hitting networks
sci-fi dramas it looks pretty compelling
and it looks like it could actually be
on that satisfaction Oh totally it looks
like it could work man I'm glad Steven
we're not a vampire
he's the only thing I'm worried about it
a very liar like several times actually
and you really yeah they played a
vampire three times
just because of that of that my family
saying like like that really is like all
he does is do that in this trailer and I
was like I wanted to see at least like
one other moment was him doing something
else yeah but he just like cuz I like I
saw the first season true what I liked
him on that show when you told me he was
in Australia I felt like oh cool like I
wonder where he's been he's the only
part of this trailer that I didn't get
anything else from other than that one
note you know what Ana fascinating about
this well Stephen Moyer
is married to his True Blood co-star
Anna Paquin ruisrock
x-men sense dude real life is x-men
rules universe that anyone's seen Alan
[ __ ] lately I wonder from the first
one to point that out
probably not yeah the effect was really
cool too you know it's always so much
good when you could get like something
with superpowers on television and
actually make them look really good Lee
Jin is a show that people when they
watch the release mr. Chiu builds up I
am seeing it I'm probably gonna be on
Netflix at some point I would definitely
just as my goal is to catch up on all
the superhero shows but I'm like every
superhero show live-action one this year
and I've been doing it consistently
every day I'm watching at least one
episode of something I'm intrigued by
this because I like the Legion and this
for having at the same time you have the
Legion is so strange and so out there
and it seems like right now it's one of
the coolest things happening in this
arena totally and this looks just as
compelling in a different way to me at
least from this one trailer this is my
first exposure to it this actually
looked like a convincing cool more
grounded more gritty like superhero
story about the characters which is
what's the most magical to me about this
genre on TV at all so yeah yeah this is
cool I'm excited to check it out for
sure I just have they honor the right
timeline definitely because x-men is
very specific about their timeline yeah
and there's no flaws there yeah never
I hope they don't mess up the timeline
in one timeline every characters they do
play by Demi Houston or Brian Cox
alright guys well hey hey thanks for
setting that trailer away you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell John is that John
Humphrey on Instagram and Twitter social
media manager of Blum house.com and you
can go check out our patreon we just did
a Google hangout today which was a total
blast with some of our patrons it was so
much fun Rosa Parra totally jumbled
Andrew Hayes were awesome Garrett to it
why weren't you there
gareth hood was on a secret mission we
don't need that sure that I could have
it go check it out we got a lot of
exclusive perks on there much love to
all you still watch this channel and if
you're new to the channel you know what
to do talk [ __ ] in the comments I'll
talk to you later
what is hugging